foreign
[Music]
welcome back greatest podcast in the
world a decision to click play and now
you're going to learn things you're
going to laugh you might even get a
little teary-eyed at the 42 minute Mark
um that is true also that's your
prediction by the way because we haven't
got there yet yeah but that's like the
whole part of the podcast is like
predicting things but your sweatshirt
looks great is that like that's kind of
who you are you're that stupid dog who
says
is he stupid no is he a monk so my uh
one of my business partner Joe he's got
that framed in a background on his wall
because this is who I am I am calm and
there's fire
you know what I'm out on by the way
I am out on the graph that's like this
is what you think progress looks like
this is what progress actually looks
like and it's like a squiggly line
instead of the straight up and to the
right line I'm out on that
what does it look like on that what
what's it look like no it's correct I'm
just out on the graphic like we know we
like if you don't know that by now like
if you're if you're over the age of 25
you actually have to report that comment
as spam when you see it on LinkedIn you
can't like it you have to say flag this
as redundant I learned this 15 years ago
and it I got it the first time I saw it
I got it never needed to see it again
dude I haven't ran Facebook ads in a
couple years but when I did what when I
ran it I think that if just one person
clicked flag as spam that had a
meaningful difference on the ad is that
still is that still the truth
uh I don't know because that's hard to
say it's hard it's like a black box now
so it's really hard to know
um but dude you gotta just fire up the
old ad manager once in a while take it
for a spin well what I used to do is any
competitor I would always click flag of
spam yeah I was gonna say there's only
one reason you know that yeah I would do
it I would do it constantly because when
I was running the ads like I would have
an ad set that got seen by like uh 10
million people and I would notice like
if two people clicked flag that would
actually make a meaningful difference in
the CPM and click-through rate and so
whenever I learned that I'm like oh
every time I see someone I don't like
flag flag it's honestly a miracle
morning Brew succeeded given that you
were doing this
more credit to them actually I couldn't
it counts just to flag them
all right let's uh wait before we get in
we do have to remind everyone about the
gentleman's agreement so in fact what
you were saying about reporting things
and clicking buttons it just did remind
me of the gentleman's agreement and what
is the agreement the agreement is think
of it as an agreement think of it as a
firm handshake done digitally between uh
two gentlemen and and one gentleman says
I will provide
and unlimited
free-flowing all you can eat buffet of
content
for the low price of zero dollars as
long as you go to YouTube you type in my
first million and you click subscribe
and I'm not just saying that so we get
more subscribers I'm saying that so that
you get more of the content that you
need I'm just looking out for you and so
that's just what one gentleman does for
another we dedicate Our Lives to this
podcast you spend 15 seconds to click
subscribe it's like that's the
gentleman's agreement we can't go to
your computer and check that you're
doing this so if you watch more than one
episode you owe it to us and that's just
the agreement yeah it's more like a
Santa you know Naughty or Nice List
thing you just need to do it just in
case
so please do that for us we work hard on
this um semi-glue tied do you want to
talk about this I've been wanting to
talk about this I'll be fairly open
about semi-glue tied I decided I will
but I so you told me let's talk about
semi-glue tied and I feel a little bit
Vindicated because I've been telling you
about this thing I I this happens a lot
I want to say I want to say a couple
months ago do you think it was a couple
months ago let's just say a couple
months ago it was a little longer than
that it was more like Sam goes
um dude I'm getting it in it's after the
recording after the recording Sam
usually unloads like one or two just
Bombshells and he's like dude I'm
getting an insane shape right now I'm
taking these drugs and I was like what
and he's like yeah I took this stuff
it's dude it's amazing I don't want to
eat any sugar hold on hold on we have to
let me set a little bit of the stage
here so I like testing new products and
that oftentimes includes body stuff I'm
just a fiend for testing stuff I love
testing everything and I'm not opposed
to injecting myself with stuff in order
to test it just like I'm not opposed to
buying a two thousand dollar thing to
test it like I just I'm I love new
technology there's clinical trials they
go phase one phase two phase three phase
Sam that's actually how drugs get to
marketing
they go straight to Sam's body I said
earlier that podcast if I drive a place
that has the world's best coffee I'm
testing it if I see a thing that says
zero symptoms miracle drug I'm testing
it
so okay so tell me uh so we'll explain
what this is so there's a there is a set
of drugs actually so I don't even really
know the medical stuff here and I don't
know how to pronounce anything so you
correct me where I'm wrong but well
first let's let's preface this like
saying none this is 100 Bro Science and
we're like Wikipedia article and like
three podcasts deep at best so take
everything what we're saying with a
grain of salt
yeah yeah don't do anything we say Okay
continue on so basically the background
of this is basically
um
there was this drug that was created to
help with diabetes and the way this
works is uh sugar Cravings basically
come from like a blood sugar imbalance
so like when you eat sweets or carbs or
drink alcohol or something like that
your body releases insulin and that like
lowers your blood sugar to a lower level
but like when your blood sugar goes up
and down that makes you crave it more so
if you've ever noticed that like you get
off sugar or like a carb heavy stuff for
30 days or you're like by week two or
three you're like great I don't actually
crave it anymore but if you just taste
it really you're like I need more I need
more
and so and so there's this uh series of
drugs that have been created for
um diabetes and you inject a very small
amount of liquid like
uh I could say with that it is but you
wouldn't even know but uh like enough to
cover a quarter like a very small amount
and you do it once a week and they did
this trial about I forget how many years
ago but they tested it with like three
or four thousand people and they gave
people this drug and originally it was
used for diabetes but then they tested
it for weight loss and they gave people
this drug and they noticed that when
they injected it in their body just once
a week over the course of around a year
they lost roughly 15 of their body
weight so what's that mean if you
weighed 300 pounds and this was for like
obese people if you weighed 300 pounds
on day one by after one year you weighed
uh what's that 45 you lost 45 pounds in
one year and people were talking about
this and they're like this is the
craziest drug I've ever I've ever take
because basically it it's an early drug
so we're not sure entirely of the side
effects so this is like the big the big
downside but like for the most part the
side effects were like my stomach hurt I
had some diarrhea but then after like
two weeks that [__] went away
um and so this drug what it does is when
you eat bad food like a sugar or
something like that or carb you can just
eat a little bit of it and you feel full
and you don't crave it anymore and it
makes it really fascinating so
ultimately what it does is it lowers
your calorie intake from like you know
eating 3000 calories a day is pretty
easy for some people now it's like no I
feel super full after 2000 I don't crave
any more food
right and this drug is being taken the
the forms of this drug it comes as like
ozampic or wegovi or there's like all
these like kind of the the brand names
of this same drug or it's class of drugs
and it's being taken by tons of
Hollywood celebrities
um Tech kind of like tech people like
Elon Musk yeah Elon Musk said he was
taking it
um who else there's a bunch of people
that that have come kind of dude
like basically what's going on with this
drug is people were using it for
diabetes and then a couple really famous
people including Elon I think there's I
think the Kardashians said they took it
and once that happened then like the the
rest of the Rich and Famous started
taking it and so like the woman from the
office the Indian lady uh Mindy or
something yeah yeah there's a lot of
people who think she's on it because she
just lost a ton of weight and then the
New York Times And The Wall Street
Journal separately each wrote articles
saying out in the Hamptons and out in LA
and Hollywood everyone is on this drug
and everyone automatically like it looks
20 pounds thinner than they did six
months prior and it's been causing a
shortage for the people who need it for
diabet diabetes yeah oat milk is out and
ozempic is in that's right so okay so
this is this is what's going on so you
told me about this a few months ago and
like most things I'm just like I don't
know what Sam's talking about sounds a
little crazy I'm just gonna sit this one
out and see what happens then I hear
about it again
then I heard about it through one of the
brand names I didn't actually realize
they were talking about the same thing
you were talking about who was talking
about it
um dude I I can't tell you how many
random places I have heard this and then
I'm on Tick Tock and there's a tick tock
doctor talking about it and I click the
comments and literally the comments are
all people with diabetes who are like
this is why I can't get my drugs like
what's going on so there's possibly
there's a ton of people with diabetes
that are like experiencing because
there's a shortage of access to uh to
these drugs right now so they're trying
to um try to keep up
so okay where do we want to go with this
so there's a couple things so basically
you were ahead of the curve you told me
about a couple months before I started
hearing about it it's still not fully
out there I wanted to talk about it now
because I think three to six months from
now
this is going to be like a household
name a lot of people are going to know
this because it's going to be on you
know CNN Fox News Group we're going to
talk about it more celebrities going to
come out about it there's going to be
controversies about it there's going to
be all sorts of things and so we want to
like call our shot and be like we talked
about it early yeah we should have
talked about it right when you said it
and it was in June by the way I started
uh learning about it in June yeah
six months ago oh man so you you've been
way ahead of the curve okay so so you
tell me about this miracle joke now I'm
like you know most people miracle drug
you know I'm skeptical initially so can
we talk about I guess like have you
looked into the science and the side
effects I asked a doctor friend and he
goes yeah these drugs they're super
effective and exactly they work uh
there's no he's like I don't know of any
uh kind of known downsides to taking
them right now but also they're so new
so like you know we'll see 10 years from
now if you know everybody's small
intestine is shriveled up into like a
little p and they what happened so well
that's that what do you know that's the
downside which is it now this particular
drug I don't actually think it's that
new like these types of things have
existed for I believe a couple decades
um but they the it is like new like on a
bigger scale
um I read like there's like this
original study that they tested this on
two or three thousand people and they
found that like the side effects are
like for some people you um like you get
muscle cramps or stomach cramps and like
some things where you're just like
uncomfortable for two or three weeks for
me when I started uh toying around with
it I got really cold I was like freezing
all day and I wanted to like wear a coat
and I thought that was just because I
was just like nine percent body fat but
I think it was partially the drug
um there's another thing where like they
there's a chance it causes thyroid
cancer but like uh they didn't that
doesn't seem like a statistically
significant thing at least not to the
point of like causing true concern I
think the biggest concern is
I don't know you don't know yet okay
yeah and we're not that's not our
especially so let's not uh talk too much
about it let's talk about some of the I
want to talk about the business side and
then I want to talk about your other
experiments that you've done oh wait
hold on you know what's interesting
though about this why this is going to
be big I think dude I think I I think
there's a world where this like cures
obesity so there was one downside which
is like the study that they everyone
lost this weight on after they quit
taking it the downside is if you were
into obesity yeah no dude the downside
was like people gained weight after they
quit taking it like they gave back like
two-thirds of the weight so like if you
don't like actually use it to create
habits and then you get off of it you're
just gonna get fat again but
um I think there's a world where it
helps like get rid of obesity I also
think there's a world I think there's a
world where it could help cure
alcoholism dude there's been people
posting I like here the reason the way I
found all the find all this stuff is I
go to forums which we could talk about
in a second but people are like I'm an
alcoholic and I start taking this and I
don't crave alcohol anymore like what's
the name of a form like Reddit or you're
talking about like deep Forum like
bodybuilding.com or something yeah yeah
so like it could be a body I will go to
bodybuilding.com or there's a Reddit
called semi-glue tied there's a Reddit
called uh uh ozenpic and we go be
there's subreddits for all of them how
many people are part of the Reddit for
semi-glue tied uh let's look right now
so
there are
14 000 not that many so that's pretty
low so like but that's cool that's
enough people that like it gets pretty
interesting and then there's another one
for like each brand name 19 000. so and
then okay so here's some kind of crazy
business stuff so
to be I'm like wow there's a there's a
miracle drug that helps you lose weight
easily and almost guaranteed until
people like tons of people and a bunch
of celebrities are doing it this thing
is going to fly so sure enough the you
know Supply starts getting uh
constrained because too many people are
trying to get it
um have you heard of some of these
brands that try to get it to you and how
create how much they're doing right now
so they're talking about the norvo the
the European company and then like the
like just the maker of it so I was
looking I was like how do I benefit from
this financially I'm not taking this
drug but how do I make some money that's
that's a different drug and um so I
looked into the you know the maker of it
the stock and then I was like okay well
um how do uh who how are people getting
this today so first search if you search
as epic is a company called calibrate
and calibrate has some crazy stats so
calibrate
let me just send you uh let me go into
calibrate.com
yeah so calibrate basically you go to
their landing page and it's like ozempic
online weight loss prescription it's a
safe doctor strive glp1 thing you know
see if you're eligible and then
basically you get it's like telemedicine
you get a call you get a prescription
you get to weight loss drug
um
they
they are currently valued at about forty
four hundred fifty million this company
in less than 24 months
um they've basically scaled to about a
50 million dollar run rate No Way really
kind of crazy so June July 2020 it's a
zero
um July 2021 it's less than like you
know it's you know it's tiny and then
it's gone up I want to say what is this
how did you see this
um I can't really say but it's gone up
you know 10x in a year
um so that's kind of crazy and they
pretty well do you know why we project
by the end of this year they'll be at 60
million and by the end of next year
they'll be at 140 million so
semi-glutide it costs like 500 bucks a
month and when you take it you're like
this is dope I'm I don't want to quit
taking this
right
hey turn off the heater I got yeah for a
Zen pick well it's like uh you like what
would you pay to like be ripped you know
what I mean you'll pay a lot yeah yeah
you know what I want turns out I won't
do is inject myself with a you know kind
of newish drug but you know I think I'm
I'm in the minority here it looks like
the majority of people are doing it so
uh there's this company there's nexmed
um obesity is a disease not a choice we
will help correct your body chemistry
with a with this drug
um okay that's pretty pretty strong
um pretty strong marketing Okay cool so
that's uh that's the first part is
people are going to Google search this
thing like crazy if you go to Google
Trends right now and you search for like
a Zen pic or you search semi-glue tied
you just see it's like basically going
up up up up up and then the the Google
Trends like you know they do this
forecast where it's like a dotted line
and the dotted line is going straight up
to a hundred is it really yeah they're
like this thing is Gonna Fly
um and so like you know I I think
there's there's gonna be a lot of people
doing this I think that if you are
creating content that is reviews
reviews science uh like some summarizing
the science around this stuff I think
that you can make a killing right now if
you can get in the top rank on SEO or on
YouTube doing reviews and
um
scientific summaries and
um FAQs on this uh on these drugs
because you will then be able to
affiliate link out that lead and if it's
500 a month and people are staying on
this thing for multiple years you might
be getting paid you know three thousand
dollars a leader ten thousand dollars a
lead or something like that right like
it could get kind of crazy depending on
what the lifetime value is of these
things and so um I think that somebody
who creates content for those Google
searches is gonna do really really well
right like if I go search I haven't
looked at all the uh so a lot of the
tools for this but well a lot of the
when I went and I went and researched
this like crazy and I used
um YouTube and I used a bunch of
different stuff to like learn about it
the majority of this content is mostly
for women who are overweight you know
it's it's a it's overweight women and I
went and I was like okay but is this
what does this drug do for like kind of
fit men I was like let's go you know
like that's like the niche that I'm
curious about like okay cool if you're
handsome podcasters
they're a niche for like uh like guy
next door like you know what I mean
um but I was like looking for like all
right so if you're 300 pounds this could
make you 200 pounds but like you know
like I don't need to be less fat like I
just want to you know how do I just I
gotta Beam on his face at a B plus body
yeah where am I going after this how can
a Missouri eight become like a New York
seven that's just what I wanted to know
that was the niche um so I was trying to
learn about it but there's like not that
much content there's some content on
about it on YouTube with like Joe Rogan
and more plates more dates talks about
it huberman is beginning to talk about
it a little bit but there's not a
significant amount right I also think
that uh owning a Facebook group of
people who are trying these things out
would be even batching it by month like
November you know ozempic bunnies and
it's like you know here we go we're all
going in how's everyone doing oh my God
it's amazing oh you're on the fence
click this link and you can get in you
know like here's here's how it works and
so I think that there's a bunch of
different ways to be an affiliate for
this stuff that so that I think is going
to do well plus obviously the companies
that are selling this stuff directly and
you don't want to take this you're not
you're not on board
uh like I don't know I'm fine like I
like I'm not like uh completely against
the idea of taking it I just uh
I play it safe when it comes to health
stuff and uh I play it safe more more
than anything else and so if there's a
lot of unknowns and it sounds a little
too good to be true I just gotta wait
and like
you know
I get shredded next year's fine two
years from now if I wait this out I'll
be okay uh look all I'm saying this
really is gonna make it so that nobody
gets fat anymore
then honestly being shredded ain't gonna
mean [__] anyways so uh not sure not
sure how I feel about it you're just
fighting the advances of of modern
science at your own loss you know what I
mean
I'm like a flat earther of the body well
and we should say like I do think that
like being natural like I P I think
there's pros and cons where they're like
people are like well I don't want to
take drugs and I'm like well like would
you keep would you take and they imply
that natural's better and I'm like I
think that's actually a stupid argument
because like I could go eat some seed
that's natural and that can kill me and
also like if you're if you're sick
do you do chemo of course you do and so
where do you draw the line as to like
what you will and will not do and I love
testing drugs and testing all my like I
said new products because I'm like I
actually want to find out where my line
is you know is your like you could be
like well I'm not gonna drive a car
that's not natural and it kills people
but I'm like yeah but it's pretty pretty
sick cars are cool like so like it kind
of makes it worth it so I I challenge
people to ask themselves and
for them they may say well I just don't
want to take anything and I say that I
think that's great do what you want but
I always think it's like an interesting
argument when people say they're
unwilling to take a certain drug and I'm
like well but you're if you drink this
Coca-Cola or if you take Advil like
where are we gonna draw the line
yeah yeah we're gonna draw the line at
things that um I already thought were
normal and new things stay out
I'm I'm what you call dug in I've made
my mind and I'm not changing okay
I have mental cleats and I'm in the
ground right now
um all right where do we go from here
um let's move on so
um
other things oh wait wait let's finish
up with weird things that you've
explored that are not so much fun so
dude this looks too good too
so vaping weed I always thought that
trade since 2004 and I used to
so nowadays because I was like why what
weed but I don't want like smoke and I
was never like a weed guy but I like I
remember thinking about this and I'm
like I don't I don't really even like
this drug but like the whole smoke thing
seems weird and so years ago I bought a
thing where I was like trying to
research it's like crazy and like
there's vaporizers but and there's this
thing called the volcano you know what
that is no it's like a 600 Vape thing
that would like put Vape in like this
plastic bag and you would talk better
and run the room and I was like that's
stupid and um so I like went and found
this like wood maker who made like an
oven that you light on fire it's
basically like a meth pipe for weed and
it Heats for the weed to like a certain
temperature and it turns into Vapes and
I was like portable Vapes this is gonna
be a thing and then like packs came out
how how far ahead of the curve are you
on that so you started vaping 2004
that's crazy uh when did vaping become
popular I feel like that's like five
years ago five years ago but I was all
my babies the other Vape that I thought
was gonna be a thing and it never turned
out
I learned about vaping alcohol turns out
that's not like there's not like that
much science to it and butt chugging is
actually the way to go but I was I was
curious about like can you actually get
drunk off of Vape so I remember like
waiting we got to put up the picture of
you with the incredible hiktan uh versus
you now and this is the like uh Olympic
infomercial how did you feel about that
that's pretty messed up right
so basically I posted a before picture
on Twitter and my before picture it
looks like I'm Kid Rock's nephew uh like
before picture honestly looks like like
somebody is staging a before picture
it's like all right how do we make this
as crazy as possible like yeah just like
turn the knob up all the way like yeah
like somebody said it looks like you got
that guy definitely has a couch in his
lawn
later that day I saw a guy get shot in
his leg with an AK-47 and a drive-by I
it was the most hectic part of my life I
was like this guy definitely has like a
a loose you know hot dog in his pocket
right now just dude I looked like a hot
dog
yeah so you um you know
you are a man of progress you're a
symbol of progress um so that that's
amazing the uh other thing you said
you're taking some like crazy wonder
drug for your uh Achilles right now you
want to talk about that or no I'm I'm
looking into this thing and I've and
I've tested it out a little bit uh it's
called bpc157 so it's a it's a peptide
which is it's hard to I I'm not a doctor
I don't even like explaining this stuff
but it's basically
um
like an amino acid and it okay we have
no public math maybe we should also have
no public science Well here here's why I
started getting interested I started
reading on Reddit on like the pept it uh
what they call the peptide Reddit and
this guy was like
my shoulder has been hurting me for 20
years and I injected myself with this
thing and like three days later I have
zero pain and I've complained for like
five years that my achilles and my calf
I like it always I'm always in pain and
so I was like screw it this one Reddit
guy I'm gonna try this out and so I did
it
my cat feels amazing I have zero pain
dude and so that's my point so
I think and this is kind of what I
wanted to talk about I so like I think
that you can find patterns
in
non-quantitative places so Facebook
groups forums
article comments
uh comments on um like when box or CNN
or whatever when they post their
articles on on Facebook looking at the
comments and 90 of it is total nonsense
but there's something interesting about
like repeatedly seeing these things like
here's a really like controversial one
that was controversial at first but now
we're like huh maybe it's not bad it's
like when you were when I I follow all
political Spectrum on Facebook so I can
see like what articles are the trends
and I'm like wow Fox keeps or Breitbart
keeps posting about Wuhan lab and like a
virus coming out of it like what what no
this we did it this didn't come out this
way but why do they keep saying this it
doesn't feel like it can't be true
someone ate a bat in their soup and that
was what happened yeah that's what I
thought but like this and this is just
one example where nowadays we're like
huh that's actually plausible maybe and
so what I try to do is whenever I see
these crazy things I try to say what's
the repeated pattern and let me ask
myself like what is the evidence not
these people are crazy or this is stupid
so like if I hear about a drug or a
product my or my I used to say you're
just nuts you're insane you don't know
anything that you're talking about
you're just be normal now I say well why
are you saying that and like is there
any evidence here's like for example
here's one that was interesting and I'm
not a political guy it just so happens
that the political things are like way
easier because there's way more of them
I saw this like crazy Instagram handle
say that Putin has cancer and he's like
close to dying
that could be total nonsense but I'm
like that's really weird that someone
would say that let me like go and
research and then like I'm like research
like oh wow you did cancel two like
things recently so I understand why you
could jump to that like conspiracy but
like it's just like interesting to see
like new ideas pop up and patterns that
repeatedly happen and then to ask
yourself why and that's typically how I
find a lot of interesting Trends another
one is like do you remember keto being
really popular yeah dude keto's dead
keto's keto's gone like I I would bet I
haven't looked at it but go to Google
Trends right now and type in keto and I
bet you it looks like a mountain like
we're on the right side of the mountain
where it's going down and uh like you
just start seeing these Trends where
like people are like who does keto
anymore or uh let you just start seeing
these things and I find that so
fascinating like to figure out where
these subcultures are on the internet
and what do people who are considered
freaks what are they believing and
actually which one of their
controversial opinions is gonna prove to
be true in like you know a couple years
you know I got to give it to you
um when you first started saying that
you saw a guy on Reddit say that his
shoulder pain went away and then you
injected yourself
I thought to myself
this guy's an idiot
but now I realize I misjudged you
you're a biohacker we just needed to
change
we just we just went from mayonnaise to
aioli and I love it
recommended by strangers on the internet
you need to say I'm part of the buyer
hacker Community yeah it's like Indiana
it's like Indiana Jones rebranding a
male purse like he nailed it that's what
I need
all right let's go to the next one
um okay I got something kind of
interesting for you so uh speaking of
Indiana Jones
I saw a clue this is actually a good
transition I saw a clip of the new
Indiana Jones trailer I don't know if
you've seen this have you seen the new
movie trailer for Indiana Jones no I
play sports and workout and stuff
[Laughter]
watch like wizard movies well
he so it's played by Harrison Ford right
but you know Indiana Jones is like the
Remake but it's Harrison Ford again and
there's in the trailer there's this one
scene where Harrison Ford who you know
he looks like uh you know
like somebody calls him Papa now like
you know he's uh he's a little older
um he like rewinds the clock and he
looks like young Harrison Ford in a
scene and I was like I think they do I
think the technical term by the way for
people of that age is gray bush that's
the preferred nomenclature show some
respect
pronouns are gray slash Bush so
so I was like how do they do that thing
where they like made him look young in
that one scene like that was pretty
pretty cool and I found out that the
South Park guys
have a company around this have you seen
this the guys created South Park have
this company called Deep voodoo and they
raised a lot of money for it they raised
20 million dollars and what they're
doing is they are creating deep fake
technology for movies so they're like yo
visual effects expensive as hell what if
we can do it using Ai and deep fakes and
the way this works is they actually were
making a movie
that required a lot of visual effects
and so they were kind of building this
technology in-house for their own
production and I think something
happened covet happened they shut down
the movie and so now the movie is not
happening but they they're like well how
do we turn this you know turn this lemon
into lemonade how do we turn this
failure into you know something that
could be successful and so they spun out
the technology as its own company and
they're like yeah we're gonna basically
do this use this technology to make it
easier to do visual effects and so then
there's this uh I put a link in our dock
here
um oh no I didn't put the link in but
there's a music video by what's his name
uh Kendrick Lamar it was amazing okay
you've seen this video it was amazing
yeah dude I was gonna I was I've been
looking into this you play sports you
exercise and you also watch rap videos
yeah
yeah podcaster I'm a cool podcaster
dude the Kendrick Lamar music video is
so good it is so good it's magic they
use this technology so what he's doing
is he's I describe it like you you know
it better than I do I've only seen it
once sounds like you actually saw it in
the wild basically if I'm uh it's just
basically a close-up of Kendrick Lamar
and it's just him rapping uh so it's
Kendrick Lamar The Heart part five it's
him sitting in a chair yep it starts off
with him then at like the one minute 45
second Mark all of a sudden his face
just changes into O.J Simpson and it
looks like he's wearing the same shirt
same hair it just just his facial
features change too identical to OJ
Simpson but he keeps rapping and it's
not like you know sometimes you see
these AI things where the mouth is like
it's like not quite moving with the
words and you would think that it'd be
pretty hard to do with rap
um but they did it it looks perfect and
it looks like OJ then he changes it to
Will Smith and he changes into Kanye
then he changes into nipsy hustle he
changes it and it just keeps morphing
and if you look at the bio it says deep
fake from Deep Voodoo special thanks to
Matt Stone Trey Parker and deep voodoo
uh for the production of this video and
so that is uh that's pretty cool and I
think this is kind of amazing these guys
these guys uh you know the South Park
guys that's kind of like a
like some people look up to Elon and
they're like wow Elon is the these
that's the that's the best it can be
career-wise you know he's the he's the
Michael Jordan
for me these guys are a little bit more
like the Michael Jordan I agreement
creation of South Park South Park's
amazing the way they went about it the
way they poured their heart and soul
into it if you ever watched that movie
what is it seven days to air have you
seen this movie yeah it's awesome man
which shows how they they produce South
Park in one week every episode is in one
in seven days and they just followed
them for like a Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday and then it's
like boom here's the the episode goes
live and all right back to the meeting
room tomorrow we got to do another one
and we do that for the whole season and
that's how they stay super topical with
their with their
um shows whereas other shows can't
because they they film the whole thing
over a longer period of time or they
animated over a longer period of time so
they can't do things that just happen
um so they did that they did Book of
Mormon so now then they they crush it at
the play
um you know Broadway play you know space
now they're doing it with this product
this uh technology companies production
company I think they just signed a 900
million dollar deal by the way with
somebody so these guys are just like
crushing what not what 900 million
dollar deal I think with a Viacom they
signed a deal I think for South Park or
uh I don't know if it's South Park or
it's other shows too but
it's That's crazy dude and I bet I
wouldn't doubt if they're each worth
something like 400 million dollars
um these guys are like prolific and
they've done it how long has South Park
been around I think like 30 years
and they're just sorry not 30 but
they're just friends dude it's great
yeah they're great man and like what's
funny is these guys make like raunchy
kid comedy and they've never had like a
blemish like they've never really done
anything wrong like the worst thing
they've ever done is like gone to like
the remember when they went to the award
ceremony on LSD and they dressed up like
JLo
no so so there was like that there was
an MTV Movie Awards where Jayla wore
this uh Jennifer Lawrence or Lopez wore
this like green dress that was like
risque and like was iconic whatever the
next year they dress up like they wore
that actually I do remember this yeah
that dress is Iconic so they tell the
story they're like yeah we just like
took a bunch of LSD and decided to do
that and they're hilarious these guys
are the best and they're super prolific
man they're awesome
laughs
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
so these guys I think they got to be our
Billy of the week
[Applause]
[Music]
a million dollars isn't cool you know
it's cool
billion
[Music]
so they signed a 900 million dollar deal
with Viacom CBS in August of 2021 Book
of Mormon their Broadway play has
grossed 500 million in revenue and they
just raised 20 million dollars for this
new deep fake company
um and basically
they say you know deep fakes have this
rap of being you know problematic
because there's going to be fake news
and there's going to be misinformation
but also it's going to be really
important for Hollywood films so things
like um de-aging the character like in
here and uh like Harrison Ford and
Indiana Jones or the music video stuff
that you saw their bet is that visual
effects are too expensive and that D
fake technology can make it much more
cost effective to do creative work and
um yeah it's kind of crazy so they they
basically the movie they had a movie
suspended due to covid they pivoted out
the team and decided to provide deep
fake tools to Hollywood
um before that the thing they were
making was a 14-minute comedy featuring
a deep faked version of Donald Trump and
so that's what got canned
um
did you just yawn during your own
segment
I've been doing a lot of talking here
you know another good another good South
Park thing another good South Park thing
that I stole from them a long time ago
was there's this video of them talking
about storytelling we've seen this where
they're like uh they're like we have one
trick when it comes to sorts the one
rule when it comes to storytelling and
um it's like they're teaching a class I
think on storytelling and they go
anywhere you can say ant and then this
happened he's like you know what when a
kid tells a boring story like I came
from school and then my mom said this
and then she said I could have some
candy and then I said I got the kitty
and then it's like this is the most
boring story ever just you know kill me
now and then yeah yeah and then is that
that key word where you're not providing
any twists and turns that would make
this an interesting story you're just
layering on more [__] more [__] more
[__] and so they're like swap that with
a but therefore
so instead you would say
I came home from school and asked my mom
for candy
but she wasn't home and she's always
supposed to be home
therefore I went outside and I started
saying mama
but the only person who was there was
this uh my neighbor who's always creepy
blah blah and so but and therefore make
for an interesting story whereas and
then makes for a boring story so they
can literally take a script and just
cross out all the sort of like and then
uh types of of connector words and
replace them with a button so or a
button therefore someone tweeted um why
do you like my first million and we got
like hundreds of replies and the Common
Thread was
um
Sean just oozes and drips Charisma and
his storytelling is so good and just
just addicting
and saying everybody laughs
one guy goes
Sean's got such good stories and he's
such a great Storyteller sorry Sam
yeah I don't know what was going on
there I think because I retweeted it so
it was like you know people who like me
I guess who were replying but um yeah
they were like you know uh the
experience the stories whatever I was
like I feel like your experience of
stories and like crazy weirdness is what
makes the podcast tick I really believe
that I think oh here's another
compliment I got for you I was actually
going to start the Pod with this I
forgot
I was when we were at that um like you
know weekend retreat or whatever uh I
had asked somebody a question I was like
because I'm trying to think about what
to do in my life right I'm like okay
sold milk Road thinking about what's
next and I was like
okay I think life comes down to like
picking the right thing to want so like
picking what you want
and then bending reality to make it
happen yeah and picking the right thing
to want in the first place
is almost even harder than becoming a
reality Bender like at this point I
believe I'm a reality Bender that was
hard that was the first 15 years and now
I realize oh shoot if I am a reality
Bender I better pick right and so I said
so I asked somebody I go I go who's
there I go man who do we know who who
are examples of people that
I feel like they pick the right things
to to care about and to work on and like
go like they pick the right goals
basically
and then they've been reality and make
them happen and I was like
who's like a plus at both of those
things
and I thought I would have this like
handful like just like a basket full of
examples that I could just be pulling
out from for inspiration
and what I found was that even the
people who I think are super smart most
of them
were picking like dumb things to to
think about care about work on right
like they were not picking well and then
a bunch of people who picked well
weren't ever gonna Bend reality to their
will it was like yeah I talked to them
five years ago still wanted that here we
are five years five years later
now no no real progress you know they're
still just Trucking along kind of like
they don't really they haven't really
figured out how to make it happen so
like I'll give you some examples of what
I mean by this so we have a buddy
I'll kind of pick on a pick on them but
I won't say his name
very successful probably worth I don't
know 100 to 200 million
um
I feel like has just been batting a
thousand like just had wins ever since
the age of like you know 24 like just
kind of first thing worked in a small
way next thing worked in a big way
now they're doing a new thing you know
that's you know or in between they
invested in a bunch of things good
Investments
um now they're doing a new thing it's
sure enough it's working and they make
it look easy to the point where I was
jealous I was like damn this person
makes it look easy and I'm like but the
problem is
and I even told them this I go I feel
like you beat the level of this video
game and then instead of going on to the
next level you just hit reset on your
Super Nintendo and play that same level
again
and you're doing that thing where you're
just almost like trying to speedrun that
same level like perfect you know like
people who play Mario and they're like
I'm gonna perfect this level right it's
like dude just go to the next level and
have a different Adventure have an
improved Adventure right like more
challenging or more
and there was first they were like when
I told them this day I was like
um they were starting a new thing it was
working everybody else was patting them
on the back being like you've done it
again it's working I can't believe how
easily you're able to make these things
work and I was sort of like
I feel that way but I also feel like
you're playing the same level of course
you're making this work again you
already know how to do this
um they did a thing recently where they
bought a company
and they were super pumped that the
company like and it was a great buy they
made a great buy they bought a company
it's not like they had a background
buying companies they just did it they
bought the right thing it wasn't
available on the market they found the
person they convinced them to sell it's
making a few million dollars of profit a
year they're gonna pay back their whole
investment in you know 15 months or
something like that it's a fantastic buy
by all accounts
but why why are you doing that what what
does that bring to your life you're
already worth you know 100 to 200
million dollars this two million dollars
a year of profit is not doing anything
except for distracting you from maybe
what you should focus on which would be
something else
and um it's kind of nitpicking you know
like a you know somebody who's you know
amazing I think at a game so I kind of
don't want it to be I don't mean it in a
negative way I just made it in men it's
really hard to find somebody who picks
the right [__] and knocks it out the
park
and what do I know as I'm brainstorming
I'm like dude I think Sam is that guy
because I thought of a couple people but
I just like last night when I was
thinking about this I was like dude Sam
is the best example let me tell you why
I remember when you were
um like you've done a bunch of things
where you're like I'm gonna motorcycle
across America
it was like like not what everybody else
was picking you weren't just following a
herd
um you then immediately went and did it
so you've done a bunch of things that
like I feel like you were choosing you
didn't just do what everybody else was
doing and each one added to your like
life value uh so it's like oh this trip
across America right or this way to make
a bunch of money uh you know because
having a bunch of money gives me this
like safety net and ability and Ammo To
Go do cool stuff even after you uh so
the newsletter was another one where
it's like what the hell is this guy
doing uh but you figure it out you've
been bent reality to your will you made
it happen and you were completely right
right I I was like oh you're gonna do a
Content company and your answer is I'm
gonna do better content and I was like
where's the disruption where's the
technology where's the new platform
what's the what's the pitch and the
pitch was like yeah like you ever read
this stuff man it's dry it's boring it
doesn't even like it doesn't speak to us
and I was like
your plan is to be less boring
right like that was literally your pitch
deck for the hustle
I called it The Daily Show effect
yeah but it's gonna be like a little
funny yeah I was like dude that is not a
pitch I remember I was trying to give
you like help I was trying to help a
friend and it turns out I needed the
help it was so stupid it was so stupid I
can't believe it worked if I'm being
honest like I was right in a way that it
didn't become like a multi-billion
dollar company because you were doing
some like crazy crazy [__] but like so
it may not have been the right
investment so I maybe I was right there
but but who cares because you were like
dude I'm gonna own 90 of this and I'm
gonna sell this I'm gonna have you know
like whatever tens of millions of
dollars in my bank account which will
let me live and do whatever the hell I
want by that time I'm 30. and then sure
enough it's exactly what you did reality
to your will you picked the right goal
you were like I'm gonna have this like
huge financial War chest by doing the
thing I know
um I'm gonna have fun build a cool brand
and meet a bunch of cool people on the
way like you did with hustlecon so you
did that then you were like all right
should I do this Airbnb thing he started
thinking about luxury airbnbs and
short-term rentals and creating a
portfolio there and I was like wow how
does he think of it like well you again
that's not where most people are going
with their next step of their career and
you started and then you and then the
thing you pick now which we don't talk
about too much now but like um
eventually yeah I think is the perfect
project for you and it's the perfect
project for where you're at I'm like
damn he did it again I even texted you
this I go your project selection was so
perfect
all I can do now is try to think of the
second best project to pick for myself
I'm always my reply to you did you
remember
uh dude you had this you know you
stopped right or something like that
yeah yeah because I actually I I didn't
want to say too much because then it'll
kind of give it away but like yeah I had
prototyped the same idea
um liked it but I was like you know
didn't have it all kind of figured out
and I wasn't really ready to go do a new
thing and so I just kind of like
I took the like the quick win and I
moved on and you were just like oh wait
that's like you know that that's
actually you figured out the right way
to do it and you're doing it and it's
amazing and it's gonna work so
dude I just want to say I think you're
that guy and I think this is a really
important thing to figure out is who are
the people that you think
um choose the right things to focus on
and then are able to bend reality to
their will because that's like the
one-two punch that is uh like most
important in life and I think that um
well thank you for those compliments you
guys one more one more it's not just
about work right so it's like
Fitness right if we showed that before
and after like you really like made it a
point
to get in phenomenal shape health-wise
that's and and not just like you're not
just like shape but like Mobility
strength athleticism like things that
actually like are de-aging right like
they're the reverse reversing aging
rather than just how many friends do we
have that just basically are like
only focused on stockpiling success and
money and you meet them and you're just
like dude like you're just going
downhill right right like the Aging is
like it's going at Double speed so yeah
you're making more money but you're
doubling your age rate by the stress the
lack of the bad lifestyle that you're
living right like it's not good
um and so that's very common and I think
you're uncommon in that the last one is
like let's say family or relationships
that sort of thing too like how do you
make it a point to be good at that right
choose the right Focus or I want to have
this great family life and then bend
reality to your will and so I think uh I
really respect that you know about you
and I think that that's something that
I'm looking for more models of that in
my life because
um I now realize that that's the most
important one-two punch well thank you I
think not to take out with you on this
podcast but yeah if you want like buy me
dinner first uh but I think you got you
you we've flattered you uh with this
tweet so you got your ego I was I was I
messaged Sean I go God these guys really
hurt my feelings
um but I think the what I learned the
reason why I'm able to do some of these
things one I think it was Guy Richie he
said something like you are the director
of your own movie uh and whenever I
heard that line I was like oh yeah like
I don't like this game I'm playing but I
also make up the rules so I'm gonna I'm
gonna make the rules for my game I'm
like it's like I only have myself to
blame if I'm not happy because I'm I
make the rules and so that kind of
changed my perspective and another thing
I was working with Sophia amoruso that
she's um The Nasty Gal that's you know
big company and then now she's got
business class this new thing she's her
and I become great friends and she was
like hey I need some help with my 2023
goal setting
and I was like cool here's
um my framework for doing this uh let's
sit down and sit for an hour and do it
and I was like Sophia how are you so
successful and you've never like written
down like what you're proud of the
previous year what you regretted what
would make you happy to accomplish this
year what those no like I'm like I was
like all right so here's how much money
how much money do you want to make what
would make you happy okay that number
all right great let's work backwards I
have a plan all right cool what about I
always do Family Fitness Fun Finance so
I'm like all right what about
relationships what would make you proud
in one year to be all right let's do
um uh uh your body uh you know where do
you want to be physically let's write
down a plan for that and like boom so we
just set aside this time that was our
worry time this was the time where we're
gonna stress and we're gonna worry about
what's gonna make us happy and we're
gonna make a guess that boom that's
gonna make us happy then we're gonna
stress on this plan
have we settled is the plan done the
plan's done I'm not worrying about it
anymore all I'm doing is executing this
the worry time is done next quarter I'll
give myself eight hours on a Sunday then
I can worry then but between now and
then there is no such thing as worry all
that all that there is is I'm executing
the plan the worry time already happened
and I've got scheduled worry time in the
future and so what I think a lot of
people don't do is they don't spend
enough time sitting down and saying what
do I want what are the rules of the game
that I'm going to play and let's create
those rules and literally write them
down and for the next some period of
time I'm going to follow those rules as
best I can
and then we're going to reassess are
those rules actually good and I don't
think people do that systematically
enough so you said something like you
know I didn't like the way that the
movie was going but then I realized I'm
the director and I could switch it like
what what was that
point and what was the movie like before
and then what what did you make a point
to switch
well um you know when I was between the
ages of like 19 and like 23 like I had
some substance issues and I got in
trouble and everything and I remember
this sounds like really lame but I
remember watching a concert it was
actually Oasis which makes us even Lamer
and they were singing a song and I
remember like watching yeah it was like
really lame I remember I was like drunk
in bed like watching this YouTube video
and I remembered like the singer was
outputting very little energy like and
yet there was a hundred thousand people
in the crowd singing back to them and
I'm like wow that's leverage man this
guy wrote this song in his bedroom and
it's like because it's such a good song
and he has such an interesting
personality that he's got like a hundred
thousand fans as well as 40 million
views repeating back to him the words
even though he's exerting a little bit
of energy that's leverage that's the
ideal way to live your life is to have
leverage and I'm wasting it and so I
remember like changing it around after I
saw that and I'm like that is uh I was
like I think I'm special enough to do
something like that I don't know how I'm
going to do it but I know I have the
ability to get there but I'm wasting it
by not leveraging myself and I can only
truly have leverage if my focus on like
what my goals are going to be so I
remember like going through that and
like that is really what changed it and
then moving to San Francisco and meeting
you meeting a couple other people and it
normalized achieving goals and then I
realized okay great I can bend the
reality easily I know how to do that now
I just got to figure out on what do I
want and then just figuring out like
what's a holistic one so I met a couple
people
um who it's like they weren't all
focused on work and I would ask them why
they're doing something and they're like
because it's sick and I was like oh
that's cool life can be fun like it
doesn't does have to be about money and
uh yeah I remember changing when I lived
in Nashville when I was a loser I was
like I'm a [__] loser right now but I
know I have a knit Factor
and when you uh you met people whoever
who had a holistic like a holistic want
is that what you called it yeah like or
I'll just like read about them so like
Laird Hamilton you know Laird Hamilton
yeah like he interests me or like Rod
dierdick were these guys and I'm like
you're just doing dumb [__] just to do
dumb [__] and they're just like yeah but
it's fun and I'm like oh my God you're
so right that it is fun I that I need to
have more fun so like I remember like
reading or talking about them on the Pod
and that like kind of has changed a
little bit too
yeah and you kind of seem to like these
people that um
like they kind of chart their own path
or they're like they just they do it
somewhat like uh
like Rob Dyrdek you know it's like he's
a skateboarder makes a kind of like a
show that's like um you know hanging out
with his friends and it's like the
Fantasy Factory and like all this stuff
right like it's kind of like
you're fun but it's like have fun on
blast or have turn your fun into a
business in some way right is that is
that kind of like a good description
like why do you like those personalities
more than
um you know whoever you know the the
traditional people that people look up
to like I don't think most people in in
who are entrepreneurs when you say
who do you think's kind of got it
figured out or who did you look up to
they're not like Laird Hamilton and Rob
Dyrdek right that's like a unique thing
to say so why is that because most
people don't live life intensely enough
and because they and they I think they
don't live it intensely enough because
they're afraid and I'm afraid too but
then I see people do stuff so
like for example
um like wouldn't it be cool if we owned
like a farm and we just go out there and
just like shoot guns and ride
motorcycles and like have a blast like
that would be fun like if you're just
like sitting around you're like I wish I
could do that it's like cool you could
do that you're gonna make this much
money you're gonna save it you're gonna
go buy this Farm then you're gonna buy
all the motorcycles and then you're
gonna tell all your friends about it and
like now you have this thing like you
can do that like or like or some people
are like man it'd be like I like cars
I'm like I wish I just had a warehouse
full of cars and I could sit around my
friends and just like Tinker on the cars
I'm like great you can do that like I I
just think that you can make any rule
you want and then like make it a reality
so that's why I just like get off on
that and I don't think people uh even
when it comes to work Fitness or fun
that they dial up the the they're living
at like a three when they it's very easy
to turn into an eight
so what would be let's say before your
20 your 20
two or whatever and now you're 30 what
are you 31 32 third uh I was born in 89.
what does that mean I'm 33 33. okay so
you're 33 years old
and I feel like you did a kind of like
you dialed up the knob on Fitness right
we saw the before and after photo I told
you I I tweeted I think I texted you two
years ago I go I'm gonna become a
fitness influencer this year yeah I know
this might not have been the right thing
to want actually maybe I'll take that
back it's not but like I the point being
I was like I'm gonna guilt myself into
getting fit right uh the second thing is
you turned up the knob on finances so
you went from broke to uh never have to
work again right like you broke to rich
um you went from you know single to you
know married and and with somebody you
love you went from
um
uh I don't know if you were having a lot
of fun then but like I think now you
have like your I have a lot of fun where
you can like go and shoot you know shoot
guns motorcycles work out you know
whatever you live in different places
different times of the year right you're
crafting that whatever lifestyle you're
you're into right now all right so
that's 33.
what's the next holistic want for you so
that 43 is is it just more of the same
like do the same thing like enjoy this
for the next 10 years or is it there's
another
so there's another level you're you're
looking to breach
um
financially if I'm not worth at least
150 million dollars by the age of 40
that would I would be considered that
would be a Miss on my goals now that's
what's the meme I'm not worth 150
million dollars you know I'm gay and my
parents die yeah
like
like obviously that's gonna have no
impact on happiness but that's just like
the goal I have
um uh so that's that's it I think well I
by the way why would you do something
that has no impact on happiness why
would you want to bench 300 pounds it's
just because that's well but like some
people do like I I because I set goals
and I hit them that's why because that's
what I do that like you know like I I
don't know I just I I thought that would
be a cool goal and I think it's really
fun the Journey of like achieving that
is cool like I think it's like uh you'd
respect yourself if you've pulled that
off yeah because I'm afraid that I can't
do it therefore that's my that's not my
goal because yeah
um so I don't know like why do you wanna
why do you wanna why do you want to be
ripped like it's I don't know if it'll
make you happy but it's like it's just a
cool little thing
um and then um I'll have kids so that
will change a thing but what I really
want is I want to own more property that
can I want to own compounds that's
really what that's that's kind of like a
goal is to have compounds so you
remember when we went to Camp MFM and um
we were at basically a compound I want a
bunch of sick ones of those and
regardless if I'm there or not I'd be
like yeah you guys go and use the
compound you could have it
um that's really what I want I care
about physical space like that I think
that that would be a a something I'm
looking forward to but
no I don't really have that many goals
other than those things I just want to
live a dope life and I'll be good at
that just just be a be a [__] man
like I get I get Pride out of being
being a man and like
well I just like look I I am fearful of
everything that everyone else is fearful
of and probably even more I would say
maybe I'm even more sensitive to that
and so I think it's fun to be like I'm
afraid to have this hard conversation
therefore I must have this hard
conversation with this person and I feel
like pride and like being a man and like
honoring you know whatever I'm afraid to
have this conversation therefore I must
have this conversation yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know what I mean like you know
what I'm saying like it feels good to
like uh be like look I'm brave I could
do it I just get I get off on those
things yeah there's a part of me that's
a lot like you and there's a part of me
that's not that way at all but it's
really funny just to see that
just dialed up to 10 and it's like yeah
that's just how he lives and that's
what's important to him like you said
it's really like what did you say oh
it's really important to be a [__]
man yeah like for me to be a lucky man
and I just found that
that's hilarious I've never I thought I
have never had well you know like
somewhere so different in that way
someone told me they're like real men
don't change their opinion based on
every little like bit of emotion or
Insight that they have and like I and I
remember up into that I remember at the
hustle and you do you do this too and
and I do this all the time where I'm
running a company and something bad
happens and I'm like oh the company's
ruined
um like our quarterly plans are [__]
Everything's Gonna Change I've got to
fire everyone and then someone told me
they're like men don't behave that way
and I was like oh you're right like like
I got to be a man about this and I
cannot let I cannot get emotional over
this some of this stuff I have to like
like no there's not been meaningful data
yet to show that I should change my
opinion this is just normal like
you had like 40 more jewelry
20 percent more uh tint on your glasses
and 80 more of an accent you could be
entertained
you're just like a few tweaks away dude
you're like a [__] I'm like making this
dish
I test the sauce little
um
Romania
Eastern European I need a little bit of
that a little by the way a little more
jewelry little man jewelry you could be
Andrew Tate I call about Andrew Tate as
having he was the like it was a breakout
Year in 2012 and then I read about what
his um uh what about what he's accused
of doing and like some of the evidence
and then I saw like a video where he
admitted it do you see the video where
he admitted it no he admitted it he like
talks about how he manipulates these
girls into being on webcam and how he
like he just says horrible [__] I want
to say that that pick is sort of like
Time Magazine making Hitler the person
of the year in 1938
like do that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was like two years before World War II
Hitler was times person of the year are
you serious I swear to God yeah I don't
know what year it was Time Magazine
Hitler person of yeah let's find out
what year it was uh 1938 yeah I was
right uh 1938 he was times person of the
year because he came in power and he
like made a lot of change but like
what a sick reference by you just now to
draw that analogy and nail the year and
talking about a magazine and work that
was dude because like here's the thing
that was wonderful because yeah by the
way Google it you could see the picture
there's like a picture of him on Time
Magazine when he was person of the year
you can be breakout of the year and also
a piece of [__] and I want to say Andrew
Tate
breakout person of the year huge piece
of [__] you got to go and see what this
guy says now also the thing about pieces
of [__] you could be 90 all right and
ninety percent of the things that you
say can be like oh yeah that's a really
good point you've just inspired me to go
work out and but ten percent of it it
could be horrible and because of that I
dislike you and that's kind of what he
does to me we're at like 90 I'm like
yeah that's a great line you're right oh
great let's Empower men to exercise and
have confidence
ooh but anytime you use the and then
someone's race I'm out you know
I actually don't know if he said that
but like anytime I hear like the Jews or
the blacks I'm like yeah I'm out dude
I'm not on board with that
all right so this is officially the Bro
episode or the Bromance episode we did
semi-glutide and the weight loss get
shredded apart we did South Park
creators as Billy of the as Billy of the
week we did uh Sam's you know therapy
session slash me sucking up to Sam
um we did be a [__] man as uh as the
internal monologue and I think this is
the Bro episode The Bromance episode I
hope uh by the way we said something the
other day we were like you know to our
four female fans
um thank you for coming we it's like uh
at every Indian wedding for some reason
my mother-in-law she has to give a
speech where she thinks individually
everybody who came from India because
there's like just like she's like they
came so far I have to say thank you this
auntie for coming stand up please and
everything and then she says and this
person came also from so far stand up
please and it's like the worst speech
you've ever seen that's how we are with
our four female fans where we're like
thank you Ashley you are still here
so so appreciate it
um sorry about the be a [__] man part
earlier is that probably boring and or
offensive
um but thank you so much and so they
they dm'd us uh after we made that joke
on the last spot and they're like hey
female fan here
um you know whatever I love it and so I
hope we just didn't lose them after this
episode we did this was not the Bro
podcast everything we said
that's good regardless of who you are be
a [__] man change it to be a [__]
woman you're all right
all right we're out of here before we
get together let's go let's leave
[Music]
foreign